Traductor: Gabriela López
Revisor: Juliana Ortega Caro
Todos merecemos una tercera oportunidad.
La primera me llegó
por nacer, por estar, por vivir.
La diaria aventura
de conocerme y reconocerme.
La segunda llegó en ese momento
justo hace tres años,
cuando mi papá antes de morir,
unos cuatro meses antes de morir,
me pidió para hablar.
Por primera vez dijo la palabra
"homosexual".
Lloramos, nos abrazamos
y todas las barreras que había aún
entre nosotros dos se desmoronaron.
Desde entonces puedo realmente
trabajar con la gente
en no solamente tolerar
eso que desconocemos,
en poder caminar y entender
qué es el respeto.
Para poder yo llegar hoy aquí,
frente en alto, verles a los ojos y decir:
"Les acepto porque me acepto".
Busco realmente todos los días
a quién darle esta llave
para que juntos trabajemos
en la inclusión.
Porque tolerar, respetar, aceptar,
eso está en ti.
Pero tomar acción es
el verdadero camino hacia la inclusión.
Esta en nosotros.
Ese es el mundo donde yo quiero vivir.
La tercera oportunidad es esta,
es todos los días.